ตอนนี้ที่เราได้ดูองค์ประกอบทั้งหมดของ VQE แล้ว มา
สรุปสิ่งที่เรียนรู้และดูว่าคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมรันมันอย่างไร
เราเริ่มต้นด้วย reference state ที่เลือกอย่างชาญฉลาด, parameterized circuit,
พารามิเตอร์เริ่มต้น และ Hamiltonian
เราส่งสิ่งเหล่านี้ไปให้คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม
ก่อนที่ Hamiltonian จะถูกรันบน ansatz state
เราต้องทำการประมวลผลคลาสสิกล่วงหน้าของ circuit
เพื่อให้ hardware ควอนตัมอ่านได้ในกระบวนการที่เรียกว่า transpilation
สิ่งสำคัญคือต้องใช้ประโยชน์สูงสุด
จากสถาปัตยกรรมของ qubit ใน hardware จริงเพื่อให้ได้ผลลัพธ์ที่ดีที่สุด
กระบวนการเหล่านี้มักจัดการโดยอัตโนมัติ เพื่อที่เราจะได้ไม่ต้อง
รู้เรื่อง qubit connectivity โดยตรง,
gate fidelity และอื่น ๆ
ตอนนี้งานคือการวัด state ที่ได้
และประมาณค่า expectation value ซึ่งจะถูก
ปรับให้เหมาะสมโดย classical optimizer
การวัดนี้ทำโดยการหมุน measurement basis
แล้วรวมผลการวัดเพื่อให้ได้ค่า expectation value
ผลลัพธ์ที่มีพารามิเตอร์นี้จะถูกส่ง
ไปให้ classical optimizer ซึ่งจะหาพารามิเตอร์ใหม่สำหรับ state
จากนั้นกระบวนการก็ทำซ้ำ
การประมวลผลคลาสสิกล่วงหน้าสร้าง parameterized circuit ใหม่
และเราใช้ Hamiltonian เดิม
สังเกตว่าในกระบวนการ VQE ทั้งหมด เราเปลี่ยนแค่ state
ผ่านพารามิเตอร์ที่เข้าใกล้ ground state มากขึ้นเรื่อย ๆ
เราทำซ้ำจนกว่าจะพอใจกับผลลัพธ์
และนั่นแหละ
ฉันชื่อ Victoria Lipinska และนี่คือคอร์ส variational quantum eigensolver